Hi. Thanks, Eva, for joining us. You gave a wonderful distinguished
lecture last month exploring the fertile area of games between learning agents.
And you're back again this month for a deeper dive with algorithms and machine learning groups here.
Very curious to hear how you trip has been going and what's bringing you back.
Microsoft Research is a great place with lots of great people. Somehow when the distinguished
lecture was set up it didn't turn out to be the best time to extend for a longer visit.
I'm now back mostly to work with Nikil, but I've been talking to other Microsoft Researchers.
This is a great group. There are a lot of great people here.
Could you go into some high-level details about the talk. You spoke the distinguished
lecture where you spoke about a new no regret model to study behavior in massive online games,
like for ad auctions and traffic routing and things like that. Could you describe some of that work?
So one interesting S fact, if you think about game series from
a CS perspective, that a lot of the games that we care about like,
I guess, Microsoft truly must care about ad auctions, but I guess
another prime example is packet routing on the Internet.
Those are really repeated games that are not happening once
but instead happening over and over every millisecond,
millions of them a day. And what's really important about them is not any single
act but instead the overall performance for any single packet on a packet routing,
if the system can deliver a packet on time, they just drop it and send it again, which works just well.
The ad auctions, every single ad is a couple of, a fraction of a cent
usually. And what's really valuable is the volume of ads here.
In these kind of setups, the classical notions of game theory
may be less applicable and it's very natural to try to use,
for the participants to try to use and explore exploits style
learning algorithms to figure out what might be good strategy.
They often don't exactly know who the opponents are -- if you're a
packet router, you don't actually know what the other team's packet,
but you can try sending it someplace and sending packets in some direction
and see what happens and that's a good way to figure out what's best.
Similar things apply, and the expiration is trying and seeing,
see how fast it gets and then okay that was a good route,
that was a bad route. Similar things happen in ad auction where there are other parameters,
I guess if you're a pizza company, you do know who are the other pizza
deliverers in town but you don't know what they're advertising,
things change, and again trying to explore what are the good
ads, what are the successful ads is a good way to learn.
If I want to employ classical learning series here, one important facet here is that the prior,
the environment in which I'm working, is not a patient prior,
because the other participants are also exploring learning.
It's not a fixed prior. In fact, the environment reacts to me. If
I start advertising very aggressively with high bids in something,
the opponent might back off and go away or might compete higher. I don't know what he'll do.
But it's not as steady patient prior environment, but instead something else. Maybe
not the worst case but something certainly where the environment reacts to me.
And in that sense this no regret learning, which is what we're using in
our work, is great because that works against the worst case adversary,
in particular it works with whatever this environment is. But one question I raised in the talk is
that an opponent who wants to himself win the ads or route his own packet is actually not worst case.
So maybe the worst case notion of the no regret theory went a little too far and the interesting example
to think about that even if we are playing two person zero-sum game so every time I win you lose --
Like rock paper scissor.
Rock paper scissor, matching pennies, whatever, your goal in playing
this game is distinctly I guess to win which means you want me to lose.
That's not the same goal as you want me to have high regret. You just
want to win. You're not worst case from the regret perspective.
You're worst case in the sense of wanting me to lose. That's not the same thing. So it
would be interesting to find a sort of law that understands these issues better but certainly
anything that works with no regret offers certain guarantees because that's a guess,
worst case opponent.
An interesting concept that came up during the talk was
this idea of a course correlated equilibrium which seemed to be --
at a high level it seemed to be that if we could get humans aware of their behavior, we could
get them all to correlate their actions in a way to achieve a better equilibrium than what we
popular know as the Nash equilibrium where everyone is selfishly looking out for themselves.
I'm very curious to hear your perspectives on why you feel that's a good equilibrium to study,
why the intersection of game theory and computer science naturally gives us algorithms
that allow us to reach such equilibrium and how we might implement this in practice.
So early work in learning and game theory, which actually started from the econ community,
not from the computer scientist, I guess maybe predating our
interest in field, or predating our interest in game theory,
was in that hoping that this learning players will reach a Nash equilibrium. Today we know that that's not
going to work out because we have computational complexity results showing that Nash equilibrium is had,
in particular simple learning algorithm can't find it because no
algorithm can or at least unless some complexity class is collapsed.
What happens when players engage in no regret-style
learning behavior is that they naturally get correlated.
And the way they get correlated is that if we are playing a game
together, we both are trying to learn our behavior from past data,
then that past data correlates us. We're learning from the same thing.
Shared history.
We have a shared history. And that shared history causes us to do something that correlates us.
So in some games, this correlation goes away and the limit
and then in the end we converge the Nash equilibrium,
but in other games we do not. And our behavior even in the limit will converge to something,
what's called correlated equilibrium. It's an analog to Nash
equilibrium except for aligning our behavior to get correlated.
So one advantage of this is that it's computationally feasible like
in particular very simple learning algorithms can converge to it,
unlike Nash equilibrium that has computational difficulties. It also is a natural model
of behavior to try to update based on data or at least I believe it is and datasets
often show that people do achieve the no regret property that the learning requires.
It's not clear it's a better mol, it's a reachable mol,
and it's a mol that contains all the Nash equilibria.
And so the Nash equilibria are particular points in the set of behaviors
and course equilibria are a convex set surrounding these points,
it's a bigger set. It's convex, which has advantages in finding it. Is it better? It's findable.
And if we can say something about all of these correlated or course corrected equilibria,
it says something powerful about all kinds of behavior including Nash equilibria.
There is a subtle issue here. If I actually make you aware
that we're playing a particular course correlated equilibria,
then you might not want to play your part. It's not always or often -- it's
not best response for you given that you know what I do to actually do it.
You can somehow think ahead, a step ahead and be a bit smarter. And maybe I can try to be a bit smarter,
too. And it's not clear what this thinking ahead behavior will do. And the reasonable
models will still stay in the big convex set of course corrected equilibria,
but it's more questionable that I can predict the behavior.
Can I predict which set the behavior will be at?
I'm not sure.
Fascinating. You mentioned the econ folks got interested in
learning and game theory together before computer scientists looked at it.
But I have a personal opinion, which is that you are one of the
first people I look up to who started thinking computationally.
My textbook that opened the world of game theory to me was
Algorithmic Game Theory with [inaudible] and you and Vazirani.
And I found it a very refreshing take --
Nisan. We should not forget Nisan as an actor.
I don't think I got the first edition. I got one of the editions.
It's Nisan. Always there.
My bad. Right. So could you give a retrospective on how game
theory evolved and how the computational subfield algorithmic game theory evolved.
I assume you want to start by giving Christos
Papadimitriou the true credit for making this evolution happen.
I heard Christos talk about game theory when I first showed up in the U.S. as a post-doc researcher,
I think, for me, the late '80s, maybe even earlier. At
that time -- so he was interested in game theory much,
much before the rest of us or many of us got interested. When
he started to take up game theory again and when this changing,
the way computer scientists think about game theory happened, is around the turn, around 2000,
maybe 1999 or 8, I'm not really sure when the first talks happened. Started to
champion the thought that for however long computer science existed as a field,
our main mission was to design algorithms, design machines, think about how
machines would work and that with the advent of the Internet this really changed.
Each designing individual machines but the most important thing is how do these machines collaborate with
each other and that we should think of the Internet via game theoretic thinking where multiple parties,
your individual laptop and my individual laptop or a router against another
router, collaborate and compete with each other in a somewhat shared,
somewhat not so shared goal. The way my laptop is optimized is not
actually trying to have good experience for the rest of the world.
It's trying to make a good experience for me to reach the Internet and that's
the same for your laptop and that's exactly what game theory tries to mold,
wherever is selfishly optimizing for themselves that's what these
machines are doing. That's a profound change in thinking.
He gave a whole bunch of talks at different conferences and really profoundly got all certainly the theoretical
computer science community but I think the broader CS community interested in this way of thinking.
The book you mentioned, he wrote the preface for it, a beautiful preface, which I recommend everyone read.
And you must read it with Noam, Vijay and Tim is wrote some
chapters and asked some other people to write chapters,
Christos included, so we can really, really, really fast react to the change of thinking.
If one person writes a book, they will take a vow, you write all
the chapters. If we ask everyone to write just one chapter each,
we can put something on the shelves of everyone very, very fast and that's what we did.
You got one to correlate and collaborate.
We collaborated. But my interest in this topic really stems from Christos' convincing argument.
I actually spent a sabbatical in Berkeley in 1999 to 2000 and that's when I decided to work on this,
in large part prompted by Christos. So while I like the idea of bringing
this, bringing computational thinking to econ or bringing game series to CS,
I should give credit where credit is due. Christos was the one that really started this evolution.
In looking ahead, we're in an on line social interaction world now and an increasingly digital life.
Seems like all the arguments you just described are even more vital.
So do you see game theory playing a vital role going forward,
like what's the outlook you have?
Definitely. You're totally right. In many different ways. One problem in applying game
theory to human behavior is that it's a totally nontrivial task to model what our incentives are.
In very simplistic game theory mols, you have a nice and clean objective function
you say traffic routers goal is to deliver the packets as fast as possible;
that humans interest is to make as much money as fast as possible,
and so on. When you have a very clean objective function,
then game theory offers a beautiful and elegant mol, what will happen in
behavior. It's less clear if you don't actually know how to mol behaviors.
So some of the examples you described are the humans involved rather than routers or automats.
We have to have a better model of what do humans really want. And one interesting thing that's happening
exactly part of the same digital revolution is that we have a lot of data traces of what people do.
So hopefully -- and this is happening, we can infer better
of actually what is a good model of human behavior,
what people actually want what objective action describes them how to model their behavior.
No regret learning is an attempt at such a behavior. It ignores a lot of different aspects.
Certainly there's some datasets we're looking at where no regret learning is not a good behavior model.
Maybe in large part because the participants don't pay enough attention. No regret learning assumed that
you actually are paying attention to what's happening and updating your behavior sufficiently often.
That's one issue. Sometimes there are other attention span or interest or how much you care,
how often you update your bits is an important parameter that's not in these models. But there are
other ways that is not a perfect behavior model of what's happening even in places like ad auctions,
thinking of advertisers that update very, very frequently so those are advertisers that clearly pay
attention and they seem to have an algorithmic tool behind them to allow them updates many times a day.
Better understanding of what drives these models and
what's important will lead to better use of game theory.
But I think game theory will remain an important tool.
And there's one interesting thing that came out
during your talk where you commented in these ad auctions,
for example, on Bing ads or something there's predictive black boxes that will give
the users entire payoff curves allows users to reason about not what is the result
of the action they took but also what if they had placed a different bid and so on.
And I realize that having access to such predictive boxes
basically allows game theory to make some kinds of assumptions,
but it can also lead to some frustrating thing where we don't know what's inside these black boxes and
that seems to tie neatly with all our efforts in trying to make these black boxes more transparent,
more interpretable and just in general there is this push
within AI to make these predictive black boxes fair,
accountable, transparent and curious where you see the potential
synergies as we start building these models of users,
how do you anticipate the interaction with game theory in the years to come.
Interesting questions you're asking and a lot of different connections
here. So maybe there are two parts that I want to separate a little bit.
So what was relevant in the ad auction model is what do players know. So
if you're a router and you chose a particular path to send your packet on,
then clearly you get no feedback of what would have happened to your packet had you sent in another path,
you'll have to send it static, too. So the feedback there is
about the path you selected and it's not about other paths.
In contrast, in ad auction, big companies, Bing included, do give better feedback. They tell the customers
if they ran a bid for a particular period of time that what they would be giving you a so-called curve,
giving you what other bids would have given you if you had, had you paid
a different bid, then your payment would have been higher and your --
but your ad would have been seen my more people. These response curves are very useful for learning.
Clearly more information, it's easier to learn. And Bing, as does Google or any other company,
does have enough information to give this, to make these
predictive curves correct. There's no prediction here.
They simply know what happened. And they can give you actual
results of what would have happened had you been tired.
They know what everybody else bid, they simply know what the bids were
and they can aggregate the numbers and tell us what the answer is.
Now, one issue they're going to raise during the talk is two advertisers trusted these curves are correct.
And I have no information whether people trust it on the Bing website. But
I do understand that there are certainly trust issues at other places.
Especially there are trust issues if you not only want to
give them past data, which is a fact you should know,
like Bing should know. But instead want to give a suggestion of what might be a good bid.
So-called recommendation, a recommended action. There are certainly trust issues and many bidders
positing and some other places prefer to use third-party optimizers due to lack of trust I believe.
Who knows if Bing may be really optimizing for me or are you optimizing for Bing itself, for the company.
And so there is the version whether I trust the data that you
provided is correct. And that might be an issue also.
A bigger issue is do I trust your recommendation. And then there is the
third issue that your recommendation might be based on machine learning,
which we don't fully understand, and it would be nice to have a better understandable mol.
Maybe they would have the trust issue, but part of the trust issue is --
Incentive.
-- incentive compatibility issue. If we're playing chess and I suggest
that you know you really should make that move but you're playing against me,
you might think is she suggesting a move that's good for me or good for her. So in this extent there is a
trust issue that's not about the lack of understanding of what causes machine learning to make a suggestion,
but instead just literally in some way we're, our incentives are aligned but in other ways they're not.
So there's possibly an incentive problem.
Does the -- I'm sure for anyone who is looking
up your work and others' work in algorithmic game theory,
they'll see the phrase mechanism design come up often. Could you explain at a high level what that
is and could some ideas from there help with this incentive alignment problem and engender trust?
Sure. Algorithmic design at a high level is
designing algorithms that would be good for selfish users.
You know, the prototypical classic example is auctioning if, we're auctioning off
a single item and we could auction it the way you contract for selling a house,
namely you make an offer and then the highest offer will get
taken, and it's going to have to pay whatever he offered,
in which case there's a lot of strategizing going into what might be the
right bid, you want to get the house but you would like to get it cheap.
And then the second prize where again the highest bidder
wins but the price you pay is the second highest bid.
That is the minimum bid he had to make in order to win, not
his actual bid. But the smallest number he could have had,
which effectively does the strategizing for you and it's easy to think through that and the second price
it's best to just tell the true maximum you're willing to pay because that's not going to be the price.
Algorithm design is to offer names that are trying to design algorithms where
the simple truthful behavior is everyone's best behavior in the system,
no matter what everyone else does, which certainly makes life easier. One issue is
using algorithm design in the kind of situations I talked about in the lecture,
that is theory that I repeated, that you have to be careful it stays -- sorry, it stays a good --
a good strategy for people to tell the truth even in the
repeated setting. For example, in a second price auction,
it does not. I tell you an iteration what my true value for this ad is about ten seconds
later the reserve price will go up just a second below my true value and look what,
suddenly I'm going to have to tell my value, pay my value. That's not going to be so good.
So there's a beautiful theory of single shot mechanisms that truth telling is a dominant strategy,
that's a good behavior for people. And we only now started to develop the area
called dynamic mechanism design that wants to develop good mechanisms that
stay good even in repeated setting design good that's in repeated setting.
Patti Bernard: Popping up from the technical level, I wanted
to ask meta level questions about the research process.
For people who are interested in game theory and were getting started reading up on the literature,
the vast fascinating literature and exciting results in dynamic
mechanisms design, it can be intimidated throwing acronyms like STOC,
FOX, EC, SODA. I'm curious, could you elaborate a bit on the community, a bit on the research process,
what it takes to make an impactful contribution.
So I guess these acronyms you're throwing around are conference names. And in fact,
interestingly, these are theory conference names. Despite this being an AI distinguished series,
I more identified as a member of the theory community. Although in the economics and computing space,
there's a lot of interaction between AI and theory. The first talk is two
theory conferences and a lot of theoretical work or some amount of theoretical
work in this game theory economics interface does get published in FOX SOC.
EC, which stands for EC, Conference of Economics and Computation is a dedicated conference
to this topic and in fact it's a conference that has a multiple different tracks,
has a theory track, has an AI track and has an empirical track, applied track. I forgot, empirical track.
And indeed the conference, the regular conference attended, there's a lot of theoreticians,
a lot of people from the AI community and even some people
from the econ community regularly show up and some,
they work at the EC. So EC has been a really great fertile
ground of mixing at the interface of AI and theory even.
Some amount of machine learning, though, actually more classical AI and the AI people like Ariel Procaccia,
or David Parkes or Santomer or a whole bunch of them that are really interested. Shorm. There's
a long list of lead AI researchers who are very interested in the game theory interface.
Often these people don't literally ask the same questions, but they're very related questions and very --
it's a really great community where people interact with each other. You asked how it makes an impact,
I mean the way that computer science and many of the fields science work,
the apprenticeship system getting Ph.D. students to work with an advisor.
And I definitely think that the way, as you point out, the literature is vast and just someone
completely on their own getting started and reading literature seem like a very hard task,
and I certainly wouldn't recommend this to people and in fact having some guidance
with someone senior in the field I think is the right way to get started.
And I guess one way this person can help you or maybe you can realize this, that some of the changes
in life and some of the changes in perspective because of our computer science perspective,
changes the kind of questions we ask. And working on those questions is incredibly impactful because these
are new questions and also maybe a little bit easier to make an impact because often you want to --
you realize that, yes, there is an amazing literature out there with a lot of beautiful work,
but this is a new question. Like, for example, I was
originally thinking of [inaudible] has a question like this.
There's a lot of beautiful work in classical game theory literature on when is
it that Nash equilibrium is guaranteed to have socially optimized outcome,
when is it that it doesn't have socially optimized outcome. But they
much less ask the question when it's not actually literally optimal.
How often is it. And it does make a difference if the welfare equilibrium is
vanishing and you're in a tragedy of the commons kind of situation versus,
yeah, we lost a little bit, it's not so bad. And making that distinction is important
and it's a question that has not been extensively studied historically in economics.
Patti Bernard: So asking these new questions based on our new perspectives can lead to impactful research.
I think so. And I think the combination of learning and games is also a bit like this.
Even though there's a history of learning of games and combination, again, I think the econ
focus was what is the kind of learning behavior that helps the players find the Nash equilibrium
and that kind of preplay or cheap talk before the game on which record it on Nash equilibrium
and I guess our perspective is the big data is thinking of learning as a behavior model.
This is what people do, not to find an equilibrium, this
is just real life, and I want to know what happens.
Patti Bernard: Right. And for students who have got started on research or early stage career researchers,
very curious if you have any advice on your organizational
principles for research or how do you balance demands on your time.
Demands on my time. I wish I balanced it better. And there are lots of things you want
to do and I guess you have to figure out what works for you for protecting some of your time.
I really like teaching. I like interacting with people who don't yet know
the field and showing them the beauty in algorithms in game theory.
But at the same time I also want to have enough impact in research. As you get older, you get asked to
do a fair amount of service and there's an impact to the community and I guess you care about that,
too. And of course all of us have some personal life. So this is not even for 24 hours but less than that,
because you might want to do other things in your life. It's a hard task and you
have to find your own balance of what might be right and what's important.
I don't know if I have really good advice. Patti Bernard: Any good
habits for being productive and asking impactful questions and research?
Any daily habits that you have that you think --
One thing that, especially since I'm doing this at Microsoft, and
maybe some of the audience are Microsoft or other industry researchers,
is I find the pressure coming from the National Science Foundation to write grant proposals very helpful.
It makes one think every couple of years how to pitch forth research not an
existing result that you already proved and you want to explain to a conference,
but in a way gets you involved in to effectively writing the
introduction in your paper before you prove the paper;
that is, before you know what results you have you need to try
to explain to someone that you will care about the results.
This is very important. You need to be able to convince yourself that what you're doing will have an impact
and it's important and it's a good idea to try to write this down and try to convince the community of
this and engage in this thinking possibly before you spend months and months figuring out the answer.
I don't know what replaces this if you're an industry researcher, but as an academic,
NSF is making me or NSF and other funding agencies making me write grant proposals.
And as annoying as it can be when the deadline pressure happens, at the high level
it's really great that people are engaging in this high level thinking of what --
I also like the idea of somewhat going with the flow and what are new and interesting questions and
keeping your eyes open of what are the research areas which are new and exciting and where the kind
of knowledge and tools that you bring to research could be impactful is something I would like to --
I did in my past. I hope I did in my past and I suggest
everyone else should be open to somewhat changing areas.
Patti Bernard: As we conclude the chat, I'm curious to hear
your outlook not only on technical side of game theory,
what interesting questions are out there, but how we might see it implemented in society or in applications,
like what's the role of government, what's the role of private actors and how might this play out.
It's a very hard question. I'm not so sure I know how to react to this. In
some way what government and the rules of government do is a form of mechanism design.
You can interfere with what's allowed and not allowed and what
are the ways we're interacting with each other as a society.
In places like ad auction companies and doing mechanism design also they're designing their mechanism but
there is a higher level version where Microsoft competes with Google or Facebook or whatever the competitors
and that mechanism design is governed by rules of the country or legal laws and stuff like that.
So that's a mechanism design also. So there are a lot of high level questions of this form.
Game theory, there's the sort of game theory of the kind I more talked about in the lecture
whose goal is more trying to understand what likely happens in the outcomes of the game,
that understanding is definitely helpful in designing rules. You
want to know what will happen before you implement a rule change.
Mechanism design is directly aiming at designing mechanisms with the goal
of making social effort high or making inequality less bad and many other
great goals that hopefully our companies and governments aim to implement.
I sincerely hope that a lot of the research that's happening here will help companies
have better mechanisms in their own space and also advice governments in some way.
That's the ultimate goal. Patti Bernard: I wanted to spend at least a sentence championing
your selfless community service and writing books and like selfless education,
your involvement with ACM and outreach efforts. I wanted to give you a
chance to like celebrate and amplify the work that you're doing in all
these other areas that make the community a worthwhile place to be a part of.
Thank you very much. Writing books -- I guess there's two books associated with me
the Algorithms Textbook with Jon Kleinberg and this Algorithmic Game Theory edited volume.
For both of them I got involved and I did it because I had a view of what I want
to tell the community and the book is an excellent way to have an impact.
Algorithms, of course, is taught at every school and required at many, many schools and
we had a way of wanting to teach the course differently than many other textbooks.
I guess one important aspect is to emphasize throughout the course how important these applications are,
rather than starting a lecture with X1 and XN are numbers and you want to do this. Every chapter,
every lecture starts with some application that explains what on the earth this X might be
and we're assigning [inaudible] to this way instead of it starting with given the numbers,
find the median. It's some sort of English story, the
company wants this or that. If you understood the story,
at the heart of it you actually learn the median. But the first
job for an undergraduate is to understand what the English said,
what did this company really want. I think this is very important, maybe
one of the most important things we're teaching as part of algorithms.
And we wanted to change the course and change the way
algorithms is taught in many, many schools to emphasize this,
I guess, often called the modeling aspect. And so we
wrote a textbook that does this. I also really liked --
and again that's another thing we do both in lectures and in the book -- is not start with
the correct algorithm but start with the first natural ID and have a lecture or in the
textbook explain of how this would be a natural thing to do but it doesn't quite work at.
You have to do a more sophisticated thing, that is to lead people how someone
saw this algorithm rather than just here's a beautiful algorithm done.
Again, that was the way I like thinking and I wanted to think, and I wanted to teach this way at Cornell.
And I love the idea that many other places adopted either the book or even when they didn't adopt the book,
they adopted this way of thinking. Algorithmic Game Theory is a bit similar. It was a new field.
We wanted to get many people involved. We wanted to get the knowledge out there. And I don't know,
I think having impact through this getting knowledge of getting a
way of thinking out there is part of what happens in teaching,
too. I did say I like teaching. I like bringing people who don't yet know anything
and bringing them algorithms or bringing them game theory or any field I know.
And a book did a little bit the same thing. So it serves the same way
of having impact. Patti Bernard: You remain an inspiration for me.
My introduction to computer science was through computer design [inaudible].
My first brush with serious computer science was a machine learning project
which crucially needed a very fast network flow algorithm as a subroutine.
Your network for algorithm. My first textbook in graduate school was Algorithm Game Theory.
And I think throughout grad school I was so fortunate to have you as my advisor, too.
Thank you very much. Patti Bernard: You have been an inspiration throughout and you remain,
and you will remain, and I'm sincerely thankful. But I also want to thank --
I want to add you were a great student to have,
because you're a more empirical machine learning student,
not on your own publishing naturally in a FOX talk community yet you seem very
interested in theoretical ideas and more willing to think what impact they have in AI.
And I think people, in order for these two fields to successfully interact with each other,
we need both sides. We need people with theoretical interests and who identify as
theoreticians to be interested in having an impact but we need people from the more
empirical community to actually be interested in reaching out and using these ideas.
And it's great to have people like you. Patti Bernard: Thanks
so much, Eva. And thanks from all of MSR for visiting us again,
and we're looking forward to many more such visits.
Thank you. It's a great place to visit.